we have a right triangle with a square
inscribed along its right angle leaving
lengths of 5 and 20. what is the area of
the square here's the textbook solution
let X be the side length of the square
then this upper triangle is similar to
this lower triangle meaning x divided by
20 is equal to 5 divided by X cross
multiplying gives x squared is equal to
5 multiplied by 20 which is equal to 100
and that's the area of the square now if
you didn't remember similar triangles
here's a fun way to solve the problem
using outside the box thinking construct
the following congruent upper triangle
and extend the sides of the square to
construct this green rectangle now
clearly these two upper triangles have
the same area and clearly these two
lower triangles have the same area
meaning the square has exactly the same
area as the green rectangle but the
green rectangle has dimensions of 5 and
20 meaning the squares area is equal to
20 times 5 which is equal to one hundred
amazing